you're trying to pull us out of the
economic crisis I don't really think so
I think it will pull itself out of the
economic crisis it's very very good job
of that but more or less each country
needs to deal with its own problems they
can export they can benefit from what
other people are doing but in the end
you can't rely on some of the country to
do it for you so China's mission and
kindness attention most properly is
going to be focused on getting itself
out of the economic crisis the rest of
the world needs to look at China and
understand that the Chinese economy is
going to be larger than every other
economy in the foreseeable future
because it's such a large country but
the the goal of you economic success is
not to be bigger than China it's to be
appropriate to your own population
Oh china is going to be a bigger bigger
part of the world but each country has
to get some bit